[Music]
in 2015
i gave a series of lectures
and discussions on the theme of
understanding
anger and they were hosted by the
kingston public library in kingston new
york
who had previously invited me for a
year of monthly lectures in 2014 the
existentialism lectures that you'll find
in another playlist
and i thought what would i like to talk
about what would people be
interested in i was doing a lot of
research
at the time as i still continue to do on
the
emotion of anger how to understand it
how to manage anger how to deal with
other people's anger
how it affects politics religion
relationships everything
under the sun and i knew that there were
a lot of other people who
not only might benefit from a talk
series on anger but
also would be quite interested in it
and i had been doing research for quite
some time
on approaches to anger in
ancient and medieval and also early
modern literary philosophical
theological and
psychological and even medical treaties
there's a lot of great
analysis discussion you know sort of
empirical observation and generalization
about this troublesome emotion ranging
throughout the western tradition
and so i thought that's what i'll do a
talk series on understanding anger so
the nine
videos that you see in this playlist
those are the lecture discussion talk
whatever you want to call them
that were hosted at the kingston public
library
and you'll notice as you're watching
them that there's a lot of different
voices coming in besides of course my
own
those are the participants some of whom
were coming every s
every session some of whom were just you
know
wandering in and everybody in between
by the end of the series it had taken on
a real momentum and we had to go to
larger and larger rooms
in order to accommodate the number of
people who were coming which was quite
gratifying
and we began in a sort of chronological
way
there's different ways of doing it you
know
we we started by looking at ancient
greek
epic and tragic poetry which means their
plays
so we looked at homer we looked at
the playwrights um you know the
tragedians
and even some comedy stuff the session
after that we looked at at anger in the
hebrew scriptures particularly
in the wisdom literature where there's a
lot of analysis devoted to it because it
was a
a big problem there as well and then we
got
into philosophy we looked at
the role that anger played in various
platonic dialogues then we looked at
aristotle the first
really scientific treat treatment of
anger
where he's looking at it in multiple
ways as a physiologist
you know kind of an unusual from our
perspective anger was
boiling around the heart of the blood um
but also as a psychologist as a
political scientist
as an ethicist and then we looked at
hellenistic philosophy the stoics on
anger
epicureans on anger plutarch discussing
anger and we even started moving into
early christian and then later christian
with thomas aquinas
views on anger and the reason why
there's only nine lectures is because we
moved from kingston new york to
where we now live here in milwaukee
wisconsin
in october so that that cut the series
short otherwise it was scheduled to go
on for 12 and we were going to look at
anger in the song of roland and in
beowulf
and we're gonna move through the middle
ages and even into the early
modern period we didn't get to that i
might resume the series sometime
down the line so what you have here is
the series
as we were able to to hold it with nine
episodes to it from you know january
all the way into september
a lot of really interesting discussions
a lot of
insights that i was bringing in from
these classic
thinkers texts and uh you know we could
even say disciplines
that a philosophy that of theology that
of literature
and so i hope that you enjoy this
playlist
and that you get something out of it and
my biggest hope
is that it will lead you to read these
authors for yourself and to
you know use them not just to understand
anger but but for understanding so many
other things because each one of them is
an entire world worth exploring on your
part
so that is the understanding anger
playlist
[Music]
you